president Trump spends his waning hours
with the Queen mean tweeting a washed-up
singer from the 70s Joe Biden does the
one thing he wasn't supposed to do and
steven crowder wins his censorship fight
with YouTube for now then a 17 year old
girl in the Netherlands commits suicide
with the blessing of the Dutch
government and her family we examined
the limits of individual liberty that
and much more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
this suicide story this question of
euthanasia where the limits of
individual liberty are and where the
government should step in where family
should step in what life means in
society this is the biggest story of the
day but it's certainly not the most
enjoyable story so we will begin with
maybe my favorite tweet the president
has ever sent definitely in the top five
we'll get to that in a second but first
raise mission is to make neighborhoods
safer and you already know about ring as
I've told you about their smart video
doorbells and cameras for a very long
time now those those cameras and
doorbells protect millions of people
everywhere they protect me ring helps
you to stay connected to your home
anywhere in the world it is like living
in the future
it's like living in the Jetsons if
there's a package delivery at your door
you can see here and speak to the person
who's coming if it's someone who's not
as nice as a delivery man if it's some
random weirdo trying to break into your
house you can do that too whether you're
in your home whether you're at the
office whether you're on a beach that's
thanks to the HD video and two-way audio
features on ring devices we have the
daily wire love ring that we are all
huge fans of it and our senior producer
Jay hae had this bizarre experience a
while ago where these drug-addled
weirdos show up to his house at 3 in the
morning
luckily I haven't had to deal with that
yet and he was lying in bed he opens it
up and there were these guys casing the
joint trying to see if they can bust
into his home and I don't know steal
something do whatever they're gonna do
he speaks to them they were shocked they
clearly are not up on the latest
technology and then they ran away
let ring protect your home to is a
listener you have a special offer and a
ring starter kit available right now
with a video doorbell and motion
activated floodlight cam or the starter
kit has everything you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home it's an unbelievable value you will
feel way safer and most importantly
you'll feel really really cool because
it's like you're living in the future
just go to ring.com slash normal skin to
wles ring.com slash knowles this tweet
that came out yesterday Donald Trump is
in the United Kingdom it is 1:30 in the
morning he's on this royal visit he is
with the Queen
and he sent out one of these tweets that
makes his entire presidency worth it
completely worth it it's been a good
president say you know I mean there have
been great victories some of the judges
some of the legislation but every so
often President Trump loses me on some
aspect of policy you know when he talks
about how we need way way more
immigration we need to increase legal
immigration you think well most of the
country actually opposes that or when
the wall doesn't get built as it's
supposed to get built or when they focus
on some crime bill like they did in in
December to try to empty out all the
prisons there sometimes I'm saying as
much as I enjoy this administration
sometimes he loses me on policy and then
I read tweets like this and I am
basically ready to dissolve the Congress
amend the Constitution and make him
president for life if we can get this
kind of high quality content into the
foreseeable future
he needs to remain president forever
this is what he tweets while he's
hanging out with the Queen 1:30 in the
United Kingdom quote washed-up psycho
Bette Midler was forced to apologize for
a statement she attributed to me that
turned out to be totally fabricated by
her in order to make your great
president that's in quotes for some
reason look really bad she got caught
just like the fake news media gets
caught a sick scammer so from now on I'm
only calling my opponents of washed-up
psychos like this this is why we are
here are we not entertained is this not
why we have come what happened here
Bette Midler who many people might not
even know who she is anymore she was a
very famous singer in the 70s and 80s
and she she actually is pretty washed-up
at this point to continue for Trump
credit she has been ranting about the
president for years now I mean well
before he ever ran for office and she
shared this meme of him which is one of
these stupid memes that goes around the
internet and there's a picture of Trump
and it had this quote beneath it which
said if I were to run for president I'd
run as a Republican because their voters
are completely stupid and they believe
whatever Fox News tells them something
like that this is ironic of course
because bette midler is sharing a meme
that is not true because she believes
whatever fake left-wing web sites tell
her so she's actually kind of embodying
the criticism
she's a lobbying at Republicans here so
she tweets this app and Donald Trump
just eviscerates her he clearly had too
much propriety while he was in the UK he
was wearing that silly white tie and
Tails and he'd been you know keeping his
manners up very nicely with the Queen so
he just needed some of those good New
York or mean tweets at night and he
tweets us at and she loses it she then
responds and says quote he actually
looks better here maybe someone in his
camp can gently give him a shiv I mean a
shove it's a picture of Trump she's
saying someone should give him a shiv
like something to stab him with oh I
mean a shove so what what's funny about
this little interaction you're talking
about three tweets right she sends out
her fake meme then he calls her a
washed-up psycho and then she says that
someone should stab him and it proves
again that Donald Trump is the king of
branding people because she is behaving
like a psycho
she is washed-up in the sense that she's
just not as popular as she was many
decades ago and she's behaving like a
psycho she sends out a fake tweet he
makes fun of her she says that we need
to murder the president he either he's
got a real keen insight into who people
are or he's just got this magical power
where he forces people to behave in the
way that he wants them to behave the big
political take away from all of this
though is not does not have to do with
Bette Midler or 1970s Broadway stores or
any of that what it has to do with is
eternally true political advice the best
defense is a good offense these days
we're seeing a lot of candidates who are
getting this backwards they think we're
gonna play it safe just don't rock the
boat too much this is kind of the idea
of the MIT Romney 2012 presidential
campaign as he said we're not going to
go on offense ever we're just gonna play
it really safe the economy under Obama
is so bad and we're gonna win the
presidency by default and what happened
he lost it's what happens the John
McCain 2008 campaign he suspended his
campaign he wanted
seemed like the really nice peaceable
elder statesman so he actually during
the financial crisis stopped campaigning
he stopped going on the offensive Obama
went on the offensive the whole time
Obama won the election president Trump
understands this he understands that you
always have to be on the attack when
political campaigns try to hold back
when they try to be circumspect when
they try to be too clever by half they
lose and when you are attacking all the
time you win you tend to win some
conservatives say that this sort of
behavior is unpresidential calling 1970s
singers washed-up psychos it's
unpresidential I get why people think
that I get why people have that reaction
but it just isn't true it's not born out
in history John Adams back in the good
old civilized old-timey days in the 19th
century John Adams referred to Alexander
Hamilton a member of his own political
party a fellow Federalist he referred to
him as the bastard brat of a scotch
peddler for whom there were not enough
[ __ ] in Philadelphia to contain his
secretions that's way worse than
anything Trump just said about Bette
Midler that is way more disgusting and
mean and crass and cruel and that was
said by a founding father of our country
about another founding father of our
country John Quincy Adams John Adams his
son and another president said of Thomas
Jefferson another president family
father author of the Declaration quote
that Jefferson was a slur upon the moral
government of the world also worse than
calling someone a washed-up psycho in
another case a little later on
US Senator william e jenner said of the
New York Governor W Averell Harriman
very famous governor he's thin boys he's
thin as I'll clean up the language a
little he's thin as urine on a hot rock
okay harry truman former president said
of richard nixon future president he's a
no-good lying bastard
Secretary of State Dean Acheson on
future President Lyndon Baines Johnson
he's a real centaur part man part
horse's ass Andrew Jackson Andrew
Jackson another very famous president
he's the man on the $20 bill he said
quote I have only two regrets I didn't
shoot Henry Clay and I didn't hang John
C Calhoun
by the way John C Calhoun was his own
vice president that's pretty bad that's
not only worse than what Donald Trump
said about Bette Midler that's worse
than what Bette Midler said about Donald
Trump which is that she wanted someone
to shave him he's saying he wanted to
shoot Henry Clay and hang John C Calhoun
president Trump is rhetorically
relatively tame compared to these two
guys what does it tell us it tells us
you don't win elections by being timid
you don't win elections by being a
really nice guy
you don't win elections by holding back
and being strategic and playing it safe
it doesn't happen and this is what Joe
Biden is hoping to do Joe Biden
unsurprisingly has learned every wrong
lesson of history not the brightest bulb
in the shed well-known plagiarist he's
lied about his academic transcripts
graduated toward the bottom of his law
school class Joe Biden thinks that he's
going to become president by hiding so
then he'll become president by default
he'll get the nomination by default and
then he's basically trying to do the MIT
Romney strategy what did what did he do
he didn't show up to campaign events on
Memorial Day Memorial is a major
campaign event of campaign events all
over the country he didn't show up to
the California Democrat convention
14 other Democrat candidates spoke at
that convention a 15th candidate showed
up though she didn't get a speaking spot
and yet Joe Biden is still at 32% in the
polls so he still has this commanding
lead over all the other candidates
number two a far distant second is
Bernie Sanders who's now crept up to 18%
everyone else is down there at 7 percent
5 percent 3 percent ok so this is good
news for Biden Doug shown with the
pollster was writing at and political
consultant he was writing at Fox News
that this is proof that the Biden
strategy is working I don't think it's
proof that it's working because if you
compare Joe Biden's very solid poll
numbers today to where they were when he
announced his campaign just in April
they're way down he's lost seven
percentage points since then we haven't
even gotten to the first democratic
debate yet he can't afford to keep
hemorrhaging all of those points he's
laying low he's trying to do the Rudy
Guiliani strategy we will show the
problem the pickle that Joe Biden is in
then we will get to many more stories
but first admit it you think that
cybercrime is something that happens to
other people
doesn't happen to you right nobody wants
your data no hackers are gonna go in and
grab your passwords or your credit card
details I actually used to be like this
I thought ah who cares no one's gonna
get my stuff it doesn't matter and then
people get into your computers wait
especially when you're on public Wi-Fi
people can get into your computer so
easily stealing data from unsuspecting
people on public Wi-Fi is one of these
simplest and cheapest ways for hackers
to make money when you leave your
internet connection unencrypted you may
as well write your passwords and your
credit card numbers on a gigantic
billboard for the rest of the world to
see so that's why I took action that's
why you should take action to to protect
yourself from cyber criminals I use
Express VPN expressvpn what does it do
it secures and anonymizes your internet
browsing by encrypting your data and
hiding your public IP address let me
tell you something if you were listening
to we're watching this show you probably
look at some pretty weird stuff on the
Internet you probably don't want that
coming out you don't want your family to
find out you want the public to know
what you're looking at out there the
expressvpn is easy to use apps that run
seamlessly in the background of your
computer phone or tablet
turning on expressvpn protection takes
only one click using it you can safely
surf on public Wi-Fi you won't be
snooped on one of your personal data
stolen
that's why expressvpn is the number one
rated VPN service by TechRadar and comes
with a 30-day money-back guarantee
protect your online activity today find
out how you can get three months for
free no reason not to do it go to
expressvpn comm slash michael mi CH AE l
exp or ESS VPN comm slash Michael for
three months for you the 1-year package
expressvpn comm slash Michael to learn
more so Joe Biden Joe Biden he would
never think to protect any of his
information don't be like Joe Biden
you know Joe Pye he wouldn't think about
this he's making the exact same mistakes
that he made in 1988 when he ran 19 a
a 98 2008 2018 we're talking about over
three decades later he makes the same
exact mistake so he's currently laying
low he's doing the Rudy Giuliani thing
don't forget in early 2008 campaign Rudy
Giuliani was at the front-runner he had
a commanding lead over the the distant
number two choice which was John McCain
and then what happened Rudy Giuliani
didn't show up he was gonna skip certain
states he wasn't gonna and what happened
Rudy Giuliani certainly never became
President Joe Biden risks that too so he
knows these gotta go out there he knows
that he's got to do something
the trouble is whenever he does anything
he puts his foot right in his mouth so
he missed of a number of campaign events
over the last two weeks he finally comes
out with his climate change platform
proposal and he blew it
he he could not have bungled this any
worse for those of you who don't
remember Biden was chased out of the
1988 presidential campaign because he
plagiarized speeches he was caught
plagiarizing speeches particularly from
the UK Labour Party politician Neil
Kinnick
here is a neil Kinnick speech and it
compared that to Joe Biden giving a
speech in 1988
the first clinic in a thousand
generations to be able to get the
University
where's Claire is the first woman in her
family in a thousand generations to be
able to get the University was it
because all our predecessors were thick
did they got talent those people who
could sing and play and recite and write
poetry and I started thinking is that's
coming over here why is it that Joe
Biden is the first in his family to go
to a university why is it that my wife
is sitting out there in the audience is
the first and her family to ever go to
college is it because our fathers and
mothers were not bright is it because
I'm the first Biden in a thousand
generations to get a college and a
graduate degree that I was smarter than
the rest those same people who read
poetry and wrote poetry and taught me
how to sing verse is it because it
didn't work hard my ancestors who worked
in the coal mines in Northeast
Pennsylvania don't come up after twelve
hours and play football for four hours
so obviously it's exactly plagiarized
from me okay Nick you might ask yourself
what kind of an idiot would steal almost
word-for-word certainly point for point
a speech given by a major UK political
leader which you've got to remember is
this was the 80s and they didn't have
the internet so now no one would do this
because you'd find it in two seconds you
google and you say up there's the clip
back then they didn't have Google they
didn't have YouTube the end of the
Internet so if some guy gives a speech
in England there's no way that anyone is
gonna find out about that in the United
States so he they obviously stole it
they thought they could get away with it
and they didn't Joe Biden also lifted
lines from JFK his brother RFK from the
1968 Democrat candidate Hubert Humphrey
and he gets chased out of the race for
that okay so here's Joe Biden's plan for
climate change this is the Biden plan
just released yesterday quote carbon
capture use and storage see see us is a
rapidly growing technology that has the
potential to create economic benefits
for Mol
simple industries while significantly
reducing carbon dioxide emissions okay
now let me read to you the blue green
Alliance brief that was sent to the
Senate Environment and Public Works
Committee in 2017 carbon capture use and
storage CC u.s. is a rapidly growing
technology that has the potential to
create economic benefits for multiple
industries while significantly reducing
carbon dioxide emissions word-for-word
Joe Biden's plan on making CC us
available quote by this goal is to make
CC USA widely available cost-effective
and rapidly scalable solution to reduce
carbon emissions to meet mid-century
climate goals now here is the carbon
capture coalition a statement on this on
the Center for climate and energy
solutions website its goal is to make CC
us widely available cost-effective been
rapidly scaleable solution to reduce
carbon emissions to meet mid-century
climate goals word for word they just
take out the word Biden's and substitute
its history repeats itself this is the
one thing this guy was not supposed to
do was plagiarized two things I guess
the other one is sniff women's hair he
was supposed to not sniff women's hair
and don't plagiarize
it's sunk his first major presidential
race and one of the first things that
Joe Biden does is plagiarized in 2019
for the 2020 race why because Joe Biden
can't help himself he can't help but be
Joe Biden this is who he is he's a
plagiarizing doofus who hasn't
accomplished anything in his political
career the closest thing he has to an
accomplishment actually is a sort of
legitimate accomplishment is this 1994
crime bill is a very tough crime bill
that that I think there's good evidence
did actually reduce crime in the country
and he actually can't run on that
because now the democrat party hates law
enforcement they want to abolish lots of
law enforcement so he can't even run on
that he's damned if he doesn't damned if
he doesn't he's hiding right now because
he knows that when he speaks he
embarrasses himself but if he keeps
hiding he's gonna hide himself away and
lose the nomination whoever dug this up
whoever figured out who
went to the Google machine and figured
out that he had plagiarized this
environmental thing he is brilliant this
was a terrific hit I know it doesn't
seem like much that he copied and pasted
from some climate website it's a huge
hit because it reminds us so many things
it reminds voters Joe Biden is really
really old because he did this in 1988
before many of us were even born it
reminds voters that he's a plagiarist
reminds voters that he's an empty suit
he doesn't have any ideas of his own he
just has to steal other people's ideas
it reminds voters that he is totally
unworthy son principled he'll just say
whatever is going to help him get
elected it reminds us that he's a
has-been he's an old joke a really great
hit really really tough open for Joe
Biden and it shows that he's I think
he's pretty vulnerable in 2020 let's get
to the biggest story of the day this
Dutch teen Noah Poe toven Noah pote
Hoeven is a 17 year old girl the story
his lit social media on fire and there's
been a lot of not quite misinformation
but a lot of confusion out there so
initially what was reported by the news
outlets is that this 17 year old girl
was euthanized this word is important
was euthanized by her government and
what is euthanasia euthanasia is a
ridiculous nonsense term which means
good death eeyew the prefix u means good
and so when it's added to in Asia
you get euthanasia which is the good
death it's obviously the opposite of a
good death it's suicide but this is the
the term the the euphemism actually
euphemism right is EU it's like a good
word to refer to something that is awful
it's a soft word that covers up a harsh
reality and so euthanasia is a euphemism
to cover up assisted suicide and after
these reports lit the world on fire if
there were then other reports to correct
them which said no this wasn't
euthanasia the government did not
actively go in and help her kill herself
so it's not euthanasia now that's also
quibbling with the word what actually
happened what actually happened is that
there was this girl who was sexually
assaulted when she was 11 12 years old
she wrote a memoir about this it gave
her depression it gave her severe
anxiety and anorexia at age 16 she
requested euthanasia she requested for a
doctor to kill her at a clinic in the
Netherlands for the past 10 years the
Netherlands has decriminalized doctor
assisted suicide and the practice has
exploded so the clinic said no they
wouldn't do it because she was too young
at age 16 to request that and her
parents didn't go along with it her
parents didn't know about it when she
made the request the next year when
she's 17 she decided to stop eating and
die
now how did she do that you might wonder
didn't her parents stop her didn't the
government stop her no they didn't so
what a lot of people are trying to say
now is this wasn't euthanasia the
government didn't help kill her the her
family didn't help kill her well sure
but they didn't stop her they permitted
her to kill herself the family actually
bought a hospital bed to have in the
home so that she could more comfortably
kill herself actually the day before she
killed herself a a Member of Parliament
in the Netherlands came and visited her
so okay they didn't give active support
well actually in a way they did because
they they bought the hospital bed they
made her comfortable at the very least
they permitted this young teenage girl
to kill herself because she was
depressed
they gave her tacit support a member of
parliament came and visited her to
comfort her as she killed herself I
guess technically this is not assisted
suicide or euthanasia or whatever you
want to call it but practically it is
it's the same thing of course it is this
is the culture of death taken to its
logical conclusion and it's not just her
since the Netherlands decriminalized
euthanasia doctor assisted suicide the
practice has exploded in 2017 6600
people in the Netherlands were killed to
resisted suicide another 19 hundred
people killed themselves through regular
old-fashioned suicide and
other 32,000 people killed themselves
through a process called palliative
sedation which is just when you have
enough sedatives and palliative medicine
pumped into your body that eventually
you die from it it's a slow version of
euthanasia and assisted suicide when you
add all of those up that means that well
over a quarter of the deaths in the
Netherlands are induced they are not
natural deaths they're suicides
when when the Netherlands first
legalized assisted suicide we were told
it was only for the extreme cases it's
Death with Dignity it's a mercy killing
for those handful of people who are in
such immense pain you would be so evil
if you said that the government can't
help them meet a good end have a good
death okay that's what how we how we
were sold this culture of death then
what happened it moved from those
extreme cases to the terminally ill
that's a distinction terminally ill
maybe you're in some pain maybe you're
not but you're not going to recover from
your illness most likely so okay then
then those people can be killed too then
it moved from the terminally ill to the
chronically ill so this is not people
who are who can see the end of the
tunnel right there it's people who are
just chronically ill they're in
discomfort and pain and so they just
rather not live like that so they'd
rather kill themselves then it moved on
from the chronically ill to people with
disabilities people who were crippled to
have physical disabilities or or mental
disabilities then it moved on to the
elderly people who are just kind of
tired of living they don't want to live
anymore
then it moved on to people with dementia
then it moved on to people with mental
illnesses 83 people in 2017 were killed
were put down in the Netherlands because
they were deemed to be mentally
deficient and then of course it moved on
to babies there was a case a year or two
ago in the Netherlands where a woman in
her 70s asked to be killed she said I am
requesting euthanasia but she had
dementia so she'd go in and out of
lucidity when they came in to do it she
was lying in her bed and the doctor gave
her a cup of poison and she said I don't
want to drink the poison the doctor said
you have to drink the boys and she said
no she pushed it away
she said you have to do it she said no
don't give me the poison her family then
held her down and the doctor killed her
while the family held her down that's
the logical conclusion of euthanasia and
nonsense word so let's say that the
Dutch government didn't give formal
approval for this seventeen year old
girl to be killed they certainly gave
their silent approval they certainly
gave their tacit approval they probably
did give their explicit approval too by
the way when the Member of Parliament
came to visit so what should have
happened here what role does the
government have in suicide what role
does the government have in a culture of
life and a culture of death it ties into
the debate we've been having for a week
or two now on individual liberty and the
true end of government we'll get to in a
second then we'll get to have Crowder
for now won his battle with YouTube of
her censorship and if there's any time
we'll get to straight Pride Parade yes
that's you heard that right there's
going to be a straight Pride Parade but
first I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube go to daily
wire.com it's ten bucks a month 100
dollars for an annual membership what do
you get you get me that should be enough
you get the Andrew Klavan show Wow
you get the Ben Shapiro sure you get the
mount wall show you get to ask questions
in the mailbag coming up on Thursday you
get to ask questions backstage you get
another Kingdom and you get this there
it is the leftist tears tumblr now
especially fortified via YouTube isn't
going to kick off one of the biggest
conservative comedians in the country go
to daily wire.com get the leftist tears
tumblr prepare for the avalanche of
leftist tears that are headed your way
don't be a washed-up psycho get the
tumblr go to daily we're calm we'll be
right back
so when the girls 16 the clinic won't
kill her but she says she wants to die
and she's going to stop eating what
should the parents have done what should
the government have done the parents
should have force-fed her what if the
parents didn't want to force-feed her
obviously they didn't they were gonna
let her kill herself they got her a
hospital bed made her comfortable in the
apartment or in the house what should
the government have done the government
should have forced fed her the
government should have gone in and
force-fed this suicidal depressed
mentally ill girl this is it takes us
back to the title of the show this is a
washed-up psycho culture that would
allow a depressed 17 year old girl to
kill herself obviously this girl
experienced trauma she was sexually
assaulted when she was 12 years old
awful really terrible that does not
justify killing yourself when you're a
teenager and by the way teenagers who
have faced all sorts of traumas and
sufferings everything from experiencing
physical assault sexual assault death of
a loved one abuse all the way to just
being a teenager all teenagers go
through some mental anguish that's the
definition of being a teenager that does
not justify killing yourself suicide as
they say is a permanent solution to a
temporary problem it is not acceptable
to kill yourself in any circumstance
that's that's the bottom line
it is a washed-up psycho culture that
thinks that it's okay to kill yourself
that thinks it's okay for a 17 year old
girl to kill yourself and this ties into
the debate over individual liberty that
we've been having for the last couple
weeks you know there's this debate on
the right that opened up because so Rob
Amari the writer at first things said
that we need to stop only talking about
individual liberty maximizing individual
autonomy we have to start talking about
what that Liberty is for what the
purpose of that Liberty is
and whether society should be oriented
toward the good towards something beyond
just letting people do whatever they
want and on the other side of that you
have the forces of liberalism classical
liberalism modern liberalism whatever
which say that Liberty however you
define it is the maximum number one
chief goal of society and government if
not the only purpose of government okay
so let me ask you something if you
believe that if you think that
individual liberty that is it that's the
be-all and end-all of government then
why is this wrong if individual liberty
is the be-all and end-all of government
the beginning in the end why is it wrong
that the government allowed this
seventeen year old girl to kill herself
is it wrong I don't know I asked this
question on Twitter and some
libertarians like Nick Gillespie over at
reason.com he sort of rejected my
premise he didn't quite answer the
question but he seemed to say no it's
not really it's Walt maybe it's wrong
that she did it but it's not wrong for
the government to allow her to do it
now maybe you would say okay it's wrong
because she's 17 and when you're 17 you
can't make any decisions and you
shouldn't have individual liberty but
when you're 18 for some reason then you
get to have individual liberty then you
get to make your own decisions then it's
totally different when you're six
seventeen years old and eleven months
and ten days then you you should have
you should not be able to make your own
decisions about ending your life but 20
days later you should be able to make
your own decisions about ending your
life okay I don't think that makes a
whole lot of sense but let's let's say
we accept that you take her being a
minor out of this let's say the girl was
18 and she was depressed and she
suffered a trauma and she wants to kill
herself why is it wrong that the
government basically encouraged her to
do it came over visited her said yeah
it's okay why is it wrong why is it
wrong to allow elderly people to kill
themselves you've got some old person
senior citizen maybe doesn't have a lot
of family left doesn't talk to a lot of
people gets depressed feels a little
lonely
or maybe does have family left and and
this elderly person feels that he's a
burden on his families wasting all of
their money and inheritance on medical
care and he's just gonna kill himself
it'll be better off for everybody he's
decided he's gonna do it he's come to
this decision on his own he's not
mentally ill he's just he's that that's
his decision should the government let
let that man do it is there something
wrong about that maybe is it possible
that the government shouldn't let that
man do it if the government should come
in and say no you shouldn't kill
yourself why why is it wrong why should
we restrict his individual liberty when
that elderly woman asked to be killed
the one who had dementia she has to be
killed then they tried to kill her and
she said no which which is her choice
which is the Liberty the time she said
she wants to be killed her the time she
said please don't kill me please don't
make me drink the poison which isn't
when was she exercising her maximum
individual liberty does it even matter
if all that matters is individual
liberty why is suicide wrong so some of
my libertarian friends I've been talking
about this with over the last few days
they say that suicide should not be
illegal does anybody really believe that
though I've heard many of my libertarian
friends say this yeah suicide is wrong
but it shouldn't be illegal the
government should just stay out of it if
some guy wants to kill himself let him
kill himself no business of mine it's
easy to say that but do you really
believe it let's say that there's a cop
cop is doing his nightly shift he drives
up to a bridge and he sees a suicidal
man a suicidal eighteen year old girl
standing on that bridge about to kill
herself does anybody really believe that
the cop should not intervene because if
suicide is illegal as it is in much of
the United States and in the civilized
world what the cop would do is say don't
jump don't jump and he would do
everything he could to come and grab her
and pull her back from the edge and then
what he would do is get her the help
that she needs get her into a mental
institution
get her into psychiatric counseling it's
not like we're gonna throw people in
jail because they've they're attempting
suicide but when there is a log in
suicide it allows the government to
intervene so that's what you that's what
would happen if there
login suicide if there's no login
suicide if it's person perfectly fine to
kill yourself then when that cop pulls
up on his nightly shift and sees the 18
year old girl at the top of the bridge
she can't say don't kill yourself
how dare he he's infringing on her
individual liberty there's no law
against it
how dare the government presumed to come
in and tell that eighteen-year-old girl
which she's gonna do with her body her
body her choice in that case it would be
profoundly wrong of the cop to try to
stop her he should if anything you
should applaud her decision
oh how wonderful eighteen year old girl
that you are exercising your liberty to
kill yourself he's the government he's
the face of the government nobody really
believes that nobody we all know on some
basic level that suicide is profoundly
wrong and that if the government showed
up if the face of the government some
cop showed up and some young girl was
gonna kill herself
he should do everything he could do to
stop her this is not to say that
individual liberty is a bad thing
individual liberty is a great thing
individual liberty is is perhaps the
most important instrument that we have
in society under normal operating
conditions it is terrific but that's not
the be-all and end-all of government we
must also be able to say that certain
things are simply wrong intrinsically
evil contrary to civilization contrary
to society contrary to law
contrary to Liberty itself even if you
just look at the argument from natural
rights we have a right to life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness
you can't pursue happiness without
Liberty and you can't have any Liberty
without life because if you take away
life you take away liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
suicide is wrong this is not a
complicated discussion it reminds me of
the people the left always does this
they try to complicate simple moral
statements they really try to make that
so for instance they'll say well the
suicide debate assisted so it's really
complicated
some people are suffering
right everybody suffers that's not a
justification for killing yourself
statistically 100% of human beings who
have ever lived have suffered well but
it's complicated no it's not suicide is
wrong
illegal immigration it's so complicated
no it's not illegal immigration is
illegal illegal is right there in the
word it's not complicated it's it's
actually the simplest issue that there
is don't do it and stop it from
happening
same thing with suicide it is simply
wrong
a healthy and vibrant culture knows that
suicide is wrong a washed-up psycho
culture can't explain why suicide is
wrong and why that despicable Member of
Parliament who visited that suicidal
girl just before she died he should have
stopped her he should have grabbed her
he should have dragged her to a
psychiatric clinic and gotten her the
help that she needed that would be a
healthy culture speaking of washed-up
psychos though that vox.com journalist
Carlos masa lost his fight for now for a
YouTube to censor steven crowder you
know the guy he he was ranting and
raving he was all upset that steven
crowder called him a a lispy queer even
though this guy Carlos masa refers to
himself as a queer so he asked YouTube
to launch an investigation YouTube goes
and launches the investigation and they
write to him quote thanks again for
taking the time to share all of this
information with us we take allegations
of harassment very seriously we know
this is important and impacts a lot of
people our team spent the last few days
conducting an in-depth review of the
videos flagged to us and while we found
the language that was clearly hurtful
the videos as posted don't violate our
policies duh they go on we've included
more info below to explain this decision
as an open platform it's crucial for us
to allow everyone from creators to
journalists to late-night TV hosts to
express their opinions within the scope
of our policies opinions can be deeply
offensive but if they don't violate our
policies they'll remain on our site even
if a video remains on our site doesn't
mean we endorse and support that
viewpoint there are other aspects of the
channel that we're still evaluating
we'll be in touch with any further
updates so they basically side with
crowder this kid Carlos masa
as a meltdown over this he says YouTube
hates gay people because they won't kick
off the people that Carlos doesn't like
good for YouTube that's really great I'm
glad they stood up for that YouTube
deserves some credit for it now the
other shoe is dropping so the New York
Times is reporting this headline YouTube
to remove thousands of videos pushing
extreme views how do you define extreme
views good question they cited steven
crowder as a reason for this move so
what the New York Times wrote was in the
videos that creator steven crowder a
conservative commentator with nearly 4
million YouTube subscribers repeatedly
insulted carlos masa a journalist from
Vox so notice what they left out there
they left out that Crowder is a comedian
comedians say offensive things if
William F Buckley Jr were on firing line
discussing some economic treatise and he
called someone LSB queer actually he did
it he did debate with gore Vidal William
F Buckley Jr actually did say listen you
queer stop calling me a Nazi or I'll
punch you in your damn face so he
actually did it once they didn't take
him off the air for it but certainly if
Buckley can get away with it comedians
should get away with it too and they
leave that out because they don't want
to admit that conservatives get to have
fun that they get to make jokes and so
they're using this as a chance to take
away other videos and this is why I
can't yet give YouTube total credit here
I think YouTube probably felt that they
couldn't take down Crowder because he's
too big I mean he's a huge publisher on
on YouTube almost 4 million subscribers
so now they're announcing a policy that
they're gonna go through and just remove
extreme videos which sounds to me like
death through a thousand cuts and that
this is all about 2020 that's what this
really comes down to activists are
ramping up to stop Trump they want to
stop Trump they want to stop Republicans
why are they doing it on social media
why are they deep platforming
conservatives trying to kick off extreme
conservatives it's because Donald Trump
won the election on social media he he
credits social media with his
presidential election obviously with the
tweets obviously with the way he
personally uses it but
so his campaign dominated on social
media I've talked to people who have
worked at YouTube and other platforms
and the Trump campaign was just much
more sophisticated at using advertising
on those platforms to reach people
the Clinton campaign was stuck in the
past Trump was built for the social
media era and so the social media
companies are now going after
Republicans and conservatives that is
what we're going to see coming into 2020
so while we celebrate Crowder's still
being on there keep an eye out because I
think the other shoe is about to drop by
the way I don't have a date for you yet
but you have to get your feather boas
out or I guess maybe not maybe the
opposite of your feather boas well there
are gay pride parades around the country
or I guess now it's LGBTQ LMNOP it's fat
pride skinny pride every single kind of
pride in the whole world it's it's way
beyond sex at this point there is now
going to be in Boston a straight Pride
Parade Boston officials are saying that
there is a group which will hold a
straight pride parade in the city over
the summer that they have not yet been
granted a permit but that they are
likely to be granted a permit and that
there will be floats and it's going to
be a very big fun deal the group that's
hosting it is called super happy fun
America and the VP of it marks ad said
that there they're going to you know go
all out quote if you would like to come
as an individual March as a group or
bring a float or vehicle get in touch
this is our chance to have a patriotic
parade in Boston as we celebrate
straight pride this is great this is a
terrific thing it's not great if it were
actually as a straight Pride Parade but
that's not what it is you can see in the
in the comment there it says we're in
have a patriotic parade by celebrating
straight pride it's a troll is what it
is it's conservatives using comedy to
expose the absurdity of the left and
conservatives should do this all the
time so why is why our gay pride parades
so bad it's not exactly the gay it's the
pride that's why fat pride and skinny
pride and all the [ __ ] pride whatever
kind of pride you want to use pride is
awful and if conservatives can
Bo's how absurd pride is to celebrate
the queen of all sins by having a
straight Pride Parade
I think that's hilarious go for it
conservatives need to use comedy that is
how you expose a washed-up psycho
culture that is how you expose an absurd
culture that is how you expose absurd
politicians and absurd policies is you
laugh at them you don't need to get
riled up and angry and scream all the
time just laugh at him kill them with
laughter and and obviously President
Trump has done this to remarkable
success conservative comedians have done
this a lot of people in the culture of
done it we need to keep it up for 2020
and and get your floats ready get go get
your floats in your bow is ready because
it looks like the conservative laughs
are not going to let up anytime soon
that's our show get your mailbag
questions then for Thursday in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 today on the
Ben Shapiro show is a culture of death
being promoted by the left that's today
on the Ben Shapiro show